we're going to go live now to
[Music]
this is the european uh
commission president speaking right
and now these dark hours
the european union and its people
stand by ukraine and its people
we are facing
an unprecedented act of aggression
by the russian leadership against a
sovereign independent country
russian's target is not only donbass
the target is not only ukraine
the target is the stability in europe
and the whole of the international peace
order
and we will hold president putin
accountable for that
later today we will present a package of
massive and targeted sanctions to
european leaders for approval
with this package
we will target strategic sectors
of the russian economy
by blocking their access
to technologies and markets that are key
for russia
we will weaken russia's economic base
and its capacity to modernize
and in addition we will freeze russian
assets in the european union and stop
the access
of russian banks to european financial
financial markets
like with the first package of sanctions
we are closely aligned
with our partners and allies the united
states the united kingdom canada but
also for example japan and australia
these sanctions are designed
to take a heavy toll
on the kremlin's interests
and their ability to finance war
and we know that millions of russians do
not want war
president putin is trying to turn the
clock back to the times of the russian
empire
but in doing so
he is putting at risk the future of the
russian people
i call on russia to immediately stop the
violence
and to withdraw its troops from
ukraine's territory
we will not let president putin tear
down the security architecture
that has given europe peace and
stability over many decades
we will not allow president putin to
replace place the rule of law
by the rule of force and ruthlessness
he should not underestimate the resolve
and strength of our democracies
and history has proven
that societies and alliances built on
trust
and freedom
are resilient and successful and that's
exactly what the autocrats fear
the european union stands with ukraine
and its people
we will continue to support them
ukraine will prevail
thank you
these are among the darkest hour
for europe since the end of world war ii
a major nuclear power
has attacked
a neighbor country
and is strengthening reprisals
of any other states
that may come to its rescue
this is not only the greatest violation
of international law
it's a violation of the basic principles
of human coexistence
it's costing many lives
with unknown consequences
ahead of us
the european union
will respond in the strongest possible
terms
president of the european council
president michel has called for a
meeting
of the european council this evening
and they will agree and provide
political guidance
to adopt
the stronger package
the harshest package of sanctions we
have ever implemented
as high representative for the foreign
affairs and security policy of the
european union
i will be in touch with our partners
around the world
to ensure the international community
will be
fully
grasping the gravity of the moment
and to call strongly
and united on russia to cease
immediately this
behavior
intolerable behavior
and russia leadership will face
unprecedented
isolation
this is not a question of blocks
this is not a question of diplomatic
power games
it's a matter of life and death
it's about the future of our global
community
and we will stand united with our
transatlantic partners
and with all european nations in
defending this position
we start united
in saying that no violence and
destruction
has means to obtain political gains
we the european union remain the
stronger group of nations in the world
and this should not be underestimated
more immediately
we will be designing
urgent assistance to ukraine
in this dire situation
we will also be active in supporting
evacuation operations
including of our own staff in zones
affected by this russian attack
the european union together with
transatlantic
like-minded partners
have made unprecedented efforts to
achieve a diplomatic solution
to the security crisis caused by russia
but russia has not reciprocated
these efforts
and instead
has opted unilaterally for a grave
and premeditated escalation conducting
the war
president putin
needs to stop this
senseless aggression
and today our thoughts
are with the people of ukraine
we will stand with them